i've known this guy for quite some time
and every single week on nfl game day
morning
uh i talked to michael irvin and
um and he's a cowboy great who i hold
fully responsible of for the dallas
cowboys
and so with that i welcome to the show
once again demarcus ware how are you
demarcus
hey rich man how you doing uh it's good
chatting with you again
it's great to talk to you um so before
we get to your app
where you're driven to win and how
you're keeping people fit through your
app
um can you make that available to the
cowboys defense
do you think hey i tell you what
something needs to happen because
from the beginning of the season all the
way until now
they really haven't showed up to be
honest with you uh i mean i
i i go back and think about when dak
was there and you know a couple of guys
were still
not hurt they were scoring 38 points
they're scoring
you know 36 points they were still
losing games but it was scoring enough
points
but the offer the defense was still
faltering
and giving up a lot of rushing yards
giving up a lot of plays
and i just go back and start thinking to
myself like what
what will cause a defense to be just so
bad
and i go back to leadership
um in the off-season which they didn't
have so you can
you know get your mantra your you know
your
what you need to sort of carry you
through the season when you start
getting that
c on your chest and who's going to be
accountable that's not there
if i ask you a question and said rich
who's the leaders on the team right now
who would you there's no answer because
i can't even find an answer
well i mean and that's the issue i i
would i guess i might say i'm but i'm
not there
uh just in just in terms of past years
obviously dak
would have been one um but jalen smith
and
and there's there are talented players
on this defense and
i'm just wondering what you thought of
because i know what i thought of and i'm
not a nine-time pro bowler heading to
the hall of fame like you
on the defensive side of the ball but
what was it like watching them have
zero discipline on on keeping either an
eye on the ball
or whatever gaps they needed to maintain
for going against an offense whose
quarterback lamar jackson who i adore
uh giving an honest answer to a simple
question i gave a few weeks ago asking
why things looked a little different
more difficult on offense this year him
saying most of the defenses they're
playing were calling out the plays
before he ran them
so here's an offense that that that many
other teams are figuring out or
you can call predictable and and
and they had an extra four days to
prepare for him because of the delays of
the game and they still gave up 300
yards
rushing what were you thinking right 300
yards rushing we're not even adding in
you know the passing yards so i always
when i was a captain when i played when
people make mistakes
that comes with not wanting to that
that's like the warranty that's the
character
that's instilled in well some of the
players are there like that
but when you start getting to a point to
where you're creating or not creating
but there's a lot of mistakes that are
made
on defense to where you know you're
going against a zone team you got a
running quarterback you
they're going to have some extravagant
plays you know you have to if you're a
defensive end you have to play cut back
boot reverse
those types of things and then you don't
do that
that becomes not a effort thing
or the coach a coaching
deal because you know what you're
supposed to do but it's like a want to
like do those guys actually want to be
out there right now playing
with each other are they actually having
that team spirit
um to where they are all together
or is everybody with demarcus launches
everybody with the jalen smith is in the
in the
the uh leighton van der ishes is that
whole defense together
um a really cohesive unit
that's the question i ask myself or
death if i was a captain that's what i
would ask the whole defense right now
are we a cohesive unit
do you actually trust me to be out there
on the football field with you
what do you think jerry jones is
thinking
um i know from
being in meeting after meeting with
jerry jones once he gets to this point
um there's going to be so many changes
that are made
from a player standpoint and he's going
to really evaluate
the scheme compared to what players are
there to be able to do it
because let's say you you have a 4-3
team
and now you got a 3-4 hybrid type
defense that you're running
and guys are making mistakes
does it come down to now personnel do
you have the right personnel because are
you playing three four
you got to have a big beast a big pinker
in the middle to be able to hold up two
guys to where
the aldon smith the demarcus lawrence's
the randy gregory's can actually arrest
a passer
you got to have good man-to-man cover
corners because now you're rushing five
so it just depends on you know like i
said i know jerry's gonna make a lot of
decisions this off-season a lot of
changes that people aren't gonna like
but he's gonna get that star uh shining
back again
well demarcus we're here on the rich
eisen show
it's it's got to start with getting dak
back in the fold right i mean yeah
um what would you what would you do on
on that front demarcus what would you do
um
as an owner uh you know for me i know
that let's say if you
franchise a player twice and then on the
third year
you work into a contract and he gets
hurt so now it's like okay well
you got to do the right thing as a owner
for yours
your team and also for the player
because you have a relationship with him
so
i would you know let him get very very
healthy
see how good he is when he comes back
hopefully he comes back 100 which i know
he will okay
um you know put him in the starting
position and
he don't pay the guy but if he comes
back and let's just say
he's not he's not who he was when he
played
i would still pay him some money because
you know he was with us
for this this time but now it's like i
also got to groom
another kid that's going to be coming in
here that's going to actually be
potential
um starter i mean i would do that i will
have to do that but also
cross my eyes and dot all the t's that i
can
to let dak know that listen i'm with you
and i'm not i actually have a heart too
i understand this business but i got a
heart too
right especially since i don't know if
the timing i don't know if they're going
to be able to
you know in all honesty depending on
free agency depending on
franchise tag um uh uh
decisions and on uh i'm gonna be deadly
honest here
um the vaccine you know if you're gonna
be able to get
people back on a field right and
practice and have otas
and things of that nature that you're
gonna have to maybe make that decision
sight unseen
and hope that you know you're seeing
within your own division
you looking up uh at a team that swept
you
partially because alex smith is balling
out
and we thought he might not even walk
again that guy had 17 surgeries
wow and and he has this this
this division in his sights while dallas
is sitting in last place
and that's the other thing too is we're
talking about the cowboys
defense being the issue and dak and
what's the question as well
while watching this team are you
surprised at how often zeke is coming
off the field
demarcus uh yeah i'm really surprised
on you know i think when you have the
bell cow
out there she wants to like you said
they want to feed zeke
but i haven't seen that in a very very
long time
to where now the third and fourth
quarter you know you get those
big running backs that just crush
defenses right
they eat the clock up they start you
know they keep the chains going i
haven't seen that
so and then i'm starting to see a lot
more pollard in there
i don't know what's going on um
and you know just going to football i
know that
um annie dalton's in there it's a new
offense
offensive quarterback in there but guess
what that's why you give the ball to
zeke
to make the quarterback comfortable
right yeah but i don't i
i don't i i don't know why
because now if you're a leader of the
team
you know you had that you had zeke now
you put the team on your back
like you said you always would do and
you run that football
control the clock and then let the
defense go out there fully rested
and create some plays for you yeah i'm
watching the giants run wayne gallman
for 135 yards and then you want to talk
about bell cows obviously there's
derrick henry there's
dalvin cook there's nick chubb who has
been crushing it
and he had he missed four weeks due to
an injury
and i i i'm just wondering where is 21
why are they not feeding him 25 30 times
a game like literally
even if it's not there in the first
quarter and a half
just start wearing people down i mean
certainly if the other team is running
it up the gut and you could clearly see
there's some gap
responsibility issues on the other side
of the ball on tuesday night i mean i'm
sitting on my couch and i'm seeing it
with my own two eyes
mike mccarthy's you know forgotten more
football than i know
mike nolan is is a guy who's been
coordinating defenses and is a defensive
minded coach for decades
i'm wondering like 21 is the answer and
and it outruns 20 and i know he's
talented but he's not
you know i i he's not making 90 million
bucks demarcus
yeah you just put the price tag on it
when you said 90 million bucks and when
you have a
a running back that's not out there 100
of the time i tell you what when they
paid me 78
i was out there in 94 place yeah out of
100
maybe six plays off but it's it's one of
those things that where
um are we using zeke the right way um
you know just i i there's so many things
that i'm trying to put my finger on
about this season like it's almost like
a whirlwind 2020 covet pandemic
like the pandemic hit dallas they hit
the dallas cowboys and
now how can they come out of it from
being sick they're sick right now can
they end the season
healthy now going to the next season
with a really good mentality
and now recouping getting the character
that that needs to be gotten during the
off-season during otas and training
camps
that can carry them through the season
it'll um correct
all the mistakes that they made this off
season and what changes are going to be
made
i'm ready to see demarcus we're here on
the rich eisen show before we talk about
your app
uh who would be your defensive player of
the year right
now jj watt pounded the table on twitter
and rightfully so for his brother tj
and you've got number 99 and we're going
to see try and track down cam tonight
uh for the rams just two of them miles
garrett was in the mix but he did
miss a couple of weeks due to covet 19.
i'm wondering who
you have uh looked at this year
and thought that's the defensive player
of the year demarcus
um i go back into you know i look at tj
watt
and what he's done and usually the mvps
are on teams that are winning and it
doesn't matter
how productive you are because i
remember when i had 20 sacks when i had
19 and a half sacks one year it didn't
matter
you know because also that
when your team's winning that goes into
leadership that goes into team
camaraderie it goes into a whole team
thing
right whole team player so with aaron
donald if i say that there was a single
player
between tj watt and aaron donald who
would win that i was aaron donald all
day
right but his team isn't doing as well
as the pittsburgh steelers
so usually the last thing that i see
is probably the last thing that i the
last person that i pick
so let's just say that now you know tj
watt they're in the super bowl
and it's him and aaron donald and
donald's not in the super bowl
but t.j watt is in a super bowl so i'm
probably going to pick tj white because
his team went further
that means in my head that they had a
better team
and so i would pick a tj watt at the
time were you talking about
mvp if you're talking about all around
categories that i just talked about yeah
through 16 weeks of a season i guess it
so if you're saying the steelers have a
better record than the rams that's who
you're taking
yeah that's what i'm taking because
that's who i'm going to see in the
postseason
and if we're going numbers for numbers
just like hey
who's the better athlete i was aaron
donald all day aaron donald
is the defensive mvp if we're just going
off of that but when you start talking
about mvp
mvp means championships
in my book so
i would say tj watt let's talk about
driven to win
so you got an app here huh i've been
working on this app for the last three
and a half years
all the content in it um i put an
enhanced experience in there
with 3d models augmented reality
artificial intelligence so
you know i've been working with
computers all my life you know that from
working with the network with you
always with the software stuff so now
being able to implement that outside of
football
affect people um in the fitness realm
and giving them an experience where you
can actually prop your phone up and put
a real argument augmented reality figure
right where you are at home
or in the gym and it'll tell you what
exercise you
do how to do it to give you your
warm-ups and activations specifically
for you
you'll be different compared to me let's
say if you as a beginner i'm gonna stick
in the beginner category because you're
really fit
and i'm gonna put me in the advanced
category because i'm not fit
so um so we're just gonna
i heard that i heard that i heard that
but please keep going use
use my show's time to promote your app
demarcus go for it i heard that
sorry no still yours go for it it's just
great
knowing that you know you can do it it's
for
anybody i also put professional athletes
in there too like specific driven
sections in there yes we're like bob
miller and leighton van der esh and
tyron smith where now you can use an
augmented reality figure put it in your
space as you if you're a kid from
college or
an nfl or if you high schooler
but also there's interviews with bond
there's workouts
with bond in there too as well um adding
on top of that
download the driven to win app in the
app store on your mobile device and
visit driven to
uh driven to win.com for more
information
and you know just like education the
best the best um
uh apps or or i guess workout apps are
to meet where
somebody is so if you are fully advanced
there is something for you there it's
not just one size fits all
and if you're somebody that looks like a
beginner but runs like a champion
uh yes demarcus you said it i didn't
um that there's something in it for
everybody
and then the thing is once you download
the app it actually is going to get you
ready for your 40-yard dash
for the comma okay so that that's going
to be great and i can't wait to see you
run that
yeah me the kenai i i hope we get to do
it this year with uh with a whole
full combine um it looks great i mean we
just put while you were going through
everything um some screen grabs and what
it looks like it
you clearly have given a ton of um
thought to it 3d visualization augmented
reality features
customized 3d avatar-led training
alongside you i mean it's pretty cool
man
congratulations on that all right thank
you so much man it was hard work and i'm
glad that now i'm able to
you know give it to give it to the
masses and now my new locker room
is a weight room where i can really just
motivate people through fitness and live
you know healthier lives i i love it um
let's do this again
um and uh because again i love your
insights your insights are phenomenal
you're excellent at this you were one of
our
uh best analysts on nfl network for for
quite some time and i i hope you do want
to get back into that end of the
business too
now that your your app is is kind of
situated um
and uh you know cause this is what you
deserve as you're going to the hall of
fame and you got a great app
and this is what i expect out of the
greatest player in the history of troy
football um to do this sort of thing
democracy
thank you so much i like that troy
football oc is going to like that
[Laughter]
who's that who's oc i don't know who
you're referring to or no no
i don't know i i didn't know he went
detroit demarcus i don't know what
you're talking about
oh he's going to get you for that well
have to find me because i'll certainly
be faster after using driven to win
uh how's
good to chat with you demarcus be well
you and your family and have a healthy
and uh safe holiday season
we'll chat all right thank you thank you
that's demarcus ware right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here